it's great to welcome back to the
program today Molly McHugh who is a
foreign policy and strategy consultant
also an information warfare expert and
someone who's been tracking the comings
and goings of not just Robert Moeller's
investigation into Trump Russia but a
lot of the other things that have been
going on including recent news that the
house Intel committee is indeed sending
a whole bunch of transcripts over to
Muller and New York prosecutors Molly
let's just kind of take a 30,000 foot
view to begin with you have those
including the acting Attorney General
who are saying this thing is almost over
you have others who are saying this
could still go on for potentially years
it's unlikely that Roger stone the raid
on Roger stones house is the last
chapter in this entire thing that
signals that there's much more to come
how should we be sort of thinking about
number one where we are in this process
and then number two how the different
investigations overlap if they do yeah I
think it's a it's a really good question
I think the the key thing is that the
mulher piece is kind of the center of a
lot of different spokes coming out of a
wheel and I think you know the the
original mandate was very much focused
on what did Russia do to interfere in
the u.s. elections and I think he has
tried to stay true to that while also
sort of sending off pieces of things
that he's discovered in the context of
reviewing Russian activities so you see
these other investigations in the
Southern District of New York and other
places there was just an indictment
yesterday in South Dakota against one of
the individuals kind of connected to all
of this so I think it's it's sort of the
Moller piece is going to be the middle
but there will be sort of cascading
pieces coming out of it for some time
including the investigations in New York
that will be relating to foreign agent
activities and the Trump family and
their finances more specifically and
then I think these congressional
investigations I think the Senate side
feels pretty good about where they ended
last year that they focused a lot on
kind of the information aspect of
Russian influence online and social
media the house side is sort of starting
a bunch of new investigations I'm
relating more to the Trump family
finances potential foreign influence
beyond
Russia into the family and then a lot of
other questions that they feel are
unanswered lines of approach on the
Russia investigation so I think there is
this kind of initial core that was
hopefully I mean hopefully what what
eventually is known from Muller is the
here's some answers to some questions
about Russia but there's probably gonna
be a lot of other questions connected to
that and I think none of this will be
done anytime soon but we need to go
through I think every different aspect
of that to understand what happened in
2016 prevented from happening again and
really look more deeply at issues of
foreign influence and corruption in our
own political system so let's talk a
little bit about the Southern District
of New York
component and then I have a bunch of
other stuff to ask you about so when the
BuzzFeed news story came out asserting
that we had finally testimony in the
hands of robert muller from michael
cohen claiming specific actions were
directed by donald trump
there was a clarification or a statement
put out by a spokesperson for robert
muller that was pretty narrowly worded
and it said that some of the
characterizations in the article about
testimony given to the special counsel
are not actually in the possession of
the special counsel and one of the
interpretations was everything in the
story could be accurate except that it
was given to the Southern District of
New York and not to the special counsel
is that a possibility number one and
then just more generally what what is
this Southern District of New York what
is their role and in the context of all
of this sure I think I think a couple of
things there I think the statement from
the special counsels office was very
specifically worded for very ambiguous
purposes I think the the statement came
at a very specific time which was
because of that story there were calls
from the hill saying wait a minute if
you have this we need this because this
indicates that this is much more serious
than what we thought we need to be
acting on this immediately and I think
the special counsels office really
wanted to interject in there to sort of
remove themselves from the political
process to dial down this sort of mob
atmosphere that was being generated from
the other side but it did not in fact
refute
you know the the sort of substance of
that depending on how you interpret the
statement and I think nobody really
knows I think BuzzFeed has gone back and
been sort of very careful about
verifying the information they just
published a huge document dump on sort
of the Trump Organization this week sort
of showing they have a lot of material
that nobody has seen so I think you'll
see a lot more of this going forward but
I think the what we've seen from from
journalistic outlets and but the very
few leaks from the special counsel's
office that have been not responded to
or interpreted as accurate as we've seen
indictments go forward there's a lot of
material at the core of this and a lot
of different parts coming off and I
think the you keep hearing commentators
on the news and whatever I'll say well
you know we're still waiting for that
smoking gun and the truth is this whole
thing is a smoking gun I mean never in
the history of our country would you
have looked at a campaign and seen in
any direction you turn Russian money
Russian influence people trying to make
contacts with Russians Russians trying
to make contact with people different
elements of financial influence going
through outside organizations outside
organizations with connections to Russia
working hard to influence the Trump
campaign or provide avenues of
communications promising different to
deliver on different aspects of sort of
policy changes all of this is absolutely
horrific
and it has been this annoying drip drip
drip I hate that phrase but plus it is
over the last few years but the body of
this is indicative of a systemic problem
relating to this campaign and the people
involved in it it could just be because
many of them have their own ethical and
corruption related issues that will
probably come out over time we've seen
some of that in the beginning of this
cabinet the number of people that have
been challenged on ethical issues many
of them are extremely wealthy and have
connections to Russian businesses before
whatever but I think it's more than that
and I think you see this sort of
building up that there was a systemic
and sort of very systematic effort from
the Russians to find avenues of
influence in the United States to
achieve very specific political
objectives and strategic goals
and it just so happened that there were
many open doors when they started
pushing on them around the Trump
Organization and the Trump campaign so I
think more of that will come out and
it's and none of it is going to be very
pretty but I think that the sort of
collective body of all of that is
already very very damning so one of the
talking points so if there's sort of
like a spectrum of opinion as on this
entire thing there is people who say
there's there's literally just nothing
here at all the witch-hunt sort of crowd
on the other side you have people who
are waiting for Trump to be forcefully
removed from office in some way as a
result of what comes from from this
investigation there's a specific sliver
in there though that says that okay that
there has been wrongdoing turned up by
this investigation but none of it
relates directly to Donald Trump and to
Donald Trump's campaign that it's stuff
that people around him did before or
it's things that haven't been
specifically tied to Trump himself what
is the truth of that as a general claim
so I think as a sort of very general
claim you can say well none of this has
Trump himself yet but I think that is
not I mean even from the details in the
current indictments the implication is
that that's not true that he's connected
to many of these activities certainly on
the business side of looking at the
attempts to make business deals with
Russia he was engaged in those
activities he knew about them he knew he
knew what was going on he was making
statements in direct connection to the
efforts to achieve a business deal with
Russia during his campaign you know I
think on his side there seems to be
already and from some of his lawyers who
are not cartoons there seems to be this
effort to lay the groundwork for to be
able to say he didn't know about any of
this this was all volunteerism on the
part of the people around him including
his own children and you know this guy
was just running for office and and what
he said himself which was well I thought
I was going to lose so you know why
shouldn't I try to make money while I'm
campaigning for president knowing that
I'm not going to win now even that is an
incredibly ridiculous statement in terms
of the ethics of public office and
seeking public office and the
corruption that he is himself implying
he is engaged in but that will be I
think a core lane of effort that they
will try to use to convince people that
he has nothing to do with this
I don't ultimately think that will be
successful because what we have seen in
every one of the indictments from Muller
and his team so far is there is an
incredible amount of data backing what
they do it's not he said she said it's
not some guy over here gave us an
interview
it's intercept material it is
communications emails phone calls text
messages documented corroborated
interactions indicating a real effort to
try to influence the Trump campaign and
the Trump campaign responding to some of
those to some of those entreaties now I
think it's important to to remain
focused on the fact that the the Moller
piece is supposed to be the Russia
aspect of this and we've seen some of it
already and that sort of hard quote
collusion piece you know is there an
email between Roger stone and and
someone in Russia saying haha we know
what we're doing I don't know that
that's ever gonna be what comes out but
I think that there's I think there's a
willingness to engage in these
activities on the part of the people who
have been indicted from the Trump team
so far including his campaign manager
his other campaign manager other people
that were acting as his advisers his
lawyers others it's just impossible for
him to say for the president to say at
some point I didn't know anything about
any of this he is known to be a
micromanager he is known to be a guy
super engaged in his own organizational
structures he has never had a big
structure around him it's always him and
a few very close acolytes and his
children and he's not a guy who wasn't
aware of all of that and I think that
will eventually be what dams him on this
when it comes to the storyline that I
mean there's sort of a bunch of
different claims that are being made
around this but the storyline generally
that you can actually trace Trump's
connection to Russia back a long time so
whether it's the video released
purporting to be from 1995 of Trump in
Russia having a meeting or whether it's
the 1987 trip or the idea that maybe
this goes through Melania give
that she's from Slovenia there may be
surreptitious connections there
whichever version of that use you want
to focus in on or all of it in general
is that do you think a good path to be
going down or should the focus really be
more the specifics of what can be proven
related to the campaign I think the the
focus for the intention or for the
purposes of the Moller investigation
should very much be that latter piece it
should be what was happening between you
know 2014 and 2017 it looks like they've
been investigating some things after he
was sworn into office as well so sort of
anything since he became focused on
running for president in the mid you
know 2010 I think should be fair game
before that I mean a lot of it is
context that's helpful I think the but
the piece of this that I think is often
ignored is yes there you know there were
contacts between Trump and the Soviet
Union various Soviet individuals in New
York when he went to the Soviet Union to
visit on an ongoing via his first wife
Ivana whose father was sort of reporting
on him as an up-and-coming businessman
to local intelligence operatives back in
the Czech Republic or Czechoslovakia at
the time you know there's there's a lot
of different lines of this but I think
if you look at the early 90s there was
sort of a core ideological concept for
the Kremlin of okay how do we rebuild
all of this influence that we've lost in
the world since the collapse of the
Soviet Union it wasn't just the loss of
territory it was the loss of sort of
greatness of being a big force at the
table of being able to have access to
everything in different groups and they
really made an effort to gain access to
cultural elites especially business and
financial elites around the world to
find these places where the resources
they had particularly in the business
and financial world could gain them
access back to decision makers and
policy makers and that's always been a
long line of effort they don't make
friends with a guy in New York and say
okay we're gonna make you president in
30 years they make friends with people
in New York knowing that most of those
people will just sort of continue on but
maybe three or four of those and
up in positions that are potentially
useful over time I think Trump was very
much on that list he was bombastic if
you know the sort of recruitment and
influence acronym is mice money ideology
compromise and ego I think in in every
aspect of that there's a way to
influence Trump in different ways I
think they knew that over time but I
think that it was initially I do believe
it was the sort of this is somebody they
could potentially be useful and that
probably evolved into something else
later on but what that tipping point was
I'm not really sure yeah and and we may
not exactly find out what that tipping
point was we've been speaking with Molly
McHugh foreign policy and strategy
consultant also an expert on information
warfare Molly great is always to talk to
you thanks for having me